The Story Behind the Legend
The Legend of Zelda is aptly named, as the
series has truly become a legend within the
gaming industry.
Every new generation of gamers have been given
the opportunity to fall in love with it through
their current Nintendo console.
Or if they’re purists, going back to the
original NES game.
However, the fundamentals have pretty much
always remained – a boy in green whose quest
is to stop an evil wizard and save the princess.
You don’t mess with perfection.
The question is- where did the inspiration
for the Legend of Zelda come from?
What inspired Nintendo to create a series
that would subsequently exhilarate millions
of gamers worldwide, many of whom would engage
in a lifelong love affair with the franchise?
This may sound familiar, but it really did
all start with a young boy…
His name was Shigeru Miyamoto, and if you’re
a seasoned gaming fan you more than likely
recognize the name.
If not, he’s the guy responsible for a couple
of small indie franchises you’ve probably
never heard of- Super Mario Bros, Donkey Kong,
F-Zero and Star Fox…
Yep, one guy.
It’s not surprising from this that he’s
known as the “father of modern gaming”.
He is also responsible for this gem of a quote:
“Video games are bad for you?
That’s what they said about rock and roll.”
In addition to the aforementioned series that
he has under his belt, Miyamoto is also the
principal creator of the Legend of Zelda.
And I wasn’t joking when I said that his
journey towards one of the greatest gaming
series of all time began when he was a boy.
Miyamoto himself has stated that his primary
inspiration for the character and the game
flow was derived from his explorations of
the hillsides surrounding his childhood town
of Sonobe, Japan.
Much like Link himself, Miyamoto would adventure
through the forests, caves, lakes and small
villages.
As he said,
“When I was a child, I went hiking and found
a lake.
It was quite a surprise for me to stumble
upon it.
When I traveled around the country without
a map, trying to find my way, stumbling on
amazing things as I went, I realized how it
felt to go on an adventure like this.”
Yet another memorable moment of adventure
for Miyamoto was when he discovered a cave
entrance and explored its interior with the
aid of a single lantern.
There presumably wasn’t an old man inside
handing out wooden swords.
As for the titular name, it was derived from
none other than the great Zelda Fitzgerald.
For those of you unfamiliar, she was the extremely
free-spirited and highly publicized (in her
day) wife of literary legend F. Scott Fitzgerald,
creator of The Great Gatsby, among a myriad
of other works.
So why did Miyamoto choose this name for his
princess?
Apparently he thought it sounded “pleasant”
and “significant.”
But what about Link?
Well, his depiction was inspired by Peter
Pan – the other green clad boy that never
seems to grow up.
Miyamoto said he wanted his protagonist to
be recognizable.
And what better way to do that than to use
a similar depiction to arguably the most well-known
boy in children’s entertainment?
As for the name, that came from the series
taking place in the past, present and future,
with the main character being the “link”
between them.
So there you have it, it started with an adventuresome
boy who loved exploring, who then became a
man who created a game about a boy who in
the process of exploring has adventures.
Seems to have worked out.
To date, depending on what source you want
to go with, the Zelda franchise has sold somewhere
between 70-80 million copies of the various
games in the franchise.
Bonus Facts:
• Zelda Fitzgerald was quite the remarkable
women in her own right, dubbed “the first
flapper”.
Her father’s position as the Chief Justice
of the Alabama Supreme Court protected her
somewhat, but also got her into the news quite
a bit when she was young for her “unladylike”
antics, such as wearing a skin-tight flesh
coloured bathing suit so it would be reported
that she swam in the nude.
As a sort of a snapshot into her philosophy
on life, it was essentially “girls just
wanna have fun”, but literally, according
to her high-school graduation photo, was:
“Why should all life be work, when we all
can borrow.
Let’s think only of today, and not worry
about tomorrow.”
That was pretty much her life in a nutshell,
only she never really needed to do the borrowing
part.
For instance, as an adult, Zelda was once
asked for her favorite recipe to cook to add
to Harper & Brothers Favorite Recipes of Famous
Women.
Not being the domestic type, she responded
with: “See if there is any bacon, and if
there is, ask the cook which pan to fry it
in.
Then ask if there are any eggs, and if so
try and persuade the cook to poach two of
them.
It is better not to attempt toast, as it burns
very easily.
Also, in the case of bacon, do not turn the
fire too high, or you will have to get out
of the house for a week.
Serve preferably on china plates, though gold
or wood will do if handy.”
• Zelda wasn’t originally too keen on
marrying F. Scott Fitzgerald, as she didn’t
like his prospects, so she continued allowing
others to court her while he went to seek
his fortunes as a writer.
F. Scott, however, was enamored with her and
was driven to succeed quickly before she accepted
someone else’ proposal for marriage.
Towards this end, besides his article writing,
he began working on his first book, This Side
of Paradise . After it was accepted to be
published, F. Scott wrote the publisher stating
that he would like the book to be published
as quickly as possible as “I have so many
things dependent on its success—including
of course a girl.”
It worked; after he sent a message to Zelda
telling her that he had a book about to be
published, she immediately accepted his proposal
for marriage and moved to New York to live
with him.
• Before signing on with Nintendo, Miyamoto
had originally intended to become a manga
artist.
• In the early going, the brass at Nintendo
weren’t too happy with the approach for
the gameplay of Zelda- where players more
or less simply explore without much in the
way of real hints as to what they’re supposed
to be doing other than assemble the triforce.
And, indeed, test groups who played the initial
game tended to get confused as to what to
do.
Miyamoto argued, and eventually convinced
the executives, that the game’s underlying
premise of just exploring and seeing what
there was to see in the world created didn’t
need to be changed.
Turns out, he was right.